what's up everybody welcome back to my
youtube channel richard on data if
you're new here my name is richard and
this is the channel where we talk about
data data science statistics and
programming subscribe for all kinds of
content just like this and hit the
notification bell so you never miss an
update this is my data science
statistics tutorial series where I give
you all the statistics knowledge that
you need to conquer the data science
world I just did a video where I talk
about the normal distribution if you
haven't seen that one yet there will be
a card for it up on the screen here I
highly recommend watching that video
before you watch this one but anyway the
normal distribution is the most popular
distribution when you have any kind of
continuous data but we also have to talk
about one of the most popular
distributions for categorical data and
that's the binomial distribution the
other super common distribution used for
categorical data is what's called the
Poisson distribution and we'll usually
use that when we have some kind of count
data the binomial distribution can show
up when we have the following
circumstances we need to have repeated
trials we need to have two possible
outcomes at each trial and we'll
typically call those success and failure
and the probability of success and
failure are the same on each and every
single trial now that all may seem a
little bit confusing or abstract so
we're going to illustrate the binomial
distribution with an example so let's
just suppose there's some disease out
there where the mortality rate is 5% put
in that a different way you could say
the survival rate is 95% now obviously
it would never be the case that
everybody in the whole world who's
exposed to this disease has the exact
same chances of surviving and dying
because obviously diseases are complex
human immune response is based on a huge
variety of factors but once you start
looking at more specific groups let's
just say really young people or really
old people this is probably a fairly
reasonable way of modeling problems like
those now let's say we have one single
subject their chance of survival is just
the overall success rate or 95
sent similarly their chance of dying is
the overall failure rate or 5% here now
when you have one single case like this
with two possible outcomes success or
failure and we know what those
probabilities are we have a very
specific case called a Bernoulli trial
also known as a Bernoulli random
variable or a Bernoulli distribution so
that's simple and straightforward enough
right now let's extend that same example
and let's suppose we have 20 people
they're all infected with this disease
the survival rate is still 95 percent
and we want to calculate the probability
that no more than one person dies here
is a case of multiple Bernoulli trials
so you have multiple trials with two
possible outcomes success or failure and
the probability is the same on every
single trial this is an application for
the binomial distribution and the
binomial distribution is completely
defined by two terms that's the sample
size and and the probability of success
often denoted by P sometimes you'll see
the failure rates denoted as Q or 1
minus P but it's just 1 minus the
success rate all right now let's look at
the formula for a binomial probability
calculation so the probability that you
have K successes given you have n trials
is this weird-lookin thing over here
it's equal to n choose k times the
probability of success to the power K
times the failure rate 1 minus P to the
power n minus K for those of you
unfamiliar with the choose function it's
basically the number of ways that you
can choose something from something else
so let's just as an example look at 3
choose 2 we have 3 balls and we want to
pick 2 out of the 3 well we could pick a
red and a green we could pick a green
and a blue or what to pick the red and
the blue so 3 choose 2 is 3 because
there's three different ways to pick two
balls the formula for the choose
function is n choose K equals n
factorial over K factorial times n minus
k factorial and any scientific
calculator in the world is going to have
both the choose function and just the
factorial function if you want to
calculate it by hand yourself now that
we understand this formula we can apply
it remember we wanted to know the
probability that no more than one person
dies now this is the exact same thing as
saying 19 or more people survive so we
could have 19 people survive or we could
have 20 people survive and we're going
to run the binomial formula for k equals
19 and k equals 20 remember that we have
20 different trials the probability of
success is 0.95 so all we really need to
do is plug in N and P we solve for the
probability x equals 19 probability x
equals 20 add them up and we get a
probability of 0.7 36 this is the chance
that no more than one person dies
equivalently 19 or more people survive
now that you hopefully see how to use
the binomial distribution to perform
probability calculations just a couple
more properties for the binomial
distribution you can calculate an
expected value a standard deviation of
variance all of that for the number of
successes the expected value is just n
times P the standard deviation is the
square root of n times P times 1 minus P
and the variance is just the square of
the standard deviation so that would be
n times P times 1 minus P forget the
square root sign now let's extend this
example again and let's say we have
5,000 subjects who were exposed to the
disease now you ask what's the mean and
standard deviation of the number of
people who are going to survive well the
mean would be 5,000 times 0.95 that's
4750 then just do the math for the
standard deviation square root of 5,000
times 0.9 5 times 1 minus 0.9 5 and
you'll get a standard deviation of 15
point 4 now suppose you were to ask if
we have 5,000 subjects what's the
probability that 4,800 or more of them
survive well actually in this case where
we have a large sample size we can
use what's called the normal
approximation to the binomial
distribution
now what's considered a large enough
sample size is not an exact science but
generally the case is if you have n
times P greater than or equal to 5 and n
times 1 minus P greater than or equal to
5 you can use the normal approximation
if you have a more conservative approach
you can change the number 5 to the
number 10 so you're comparing n times P
and n times 1 minus P to 10 instead of 5
in our case here we have more than large
enough of a sample size we can use the
normal approximation at this point all
this is is just a normal distribution
probability calculation if you've seen
my video on the normal distribution you
already know how to do these probability
calculations and we already calculated
mu and Sigma all we have to do is
calculate a z-score now so Z equals
4,800 minus 4750 divided by 15 point 4
we get a z-score of three point two five
we go to our handy normal probability
table we look up the area to the left of
z equals three point two five we see
that it's point nine nine nine four so
we have to do 1 minus that because we're
looking at the probability that Z is
greater than or equal to three point two
five so we find that probability to be
point zero zero zero six all that to say
there's point zero zero zero six
probability that 4,800 or more people
would survive I know pretty morbid right
so that wraps up how to use the binomial
distribution as well as the normal
approximation in order to do probability
calculations in practice again the
binomial distribution is super common
because there are tons of instances
where you can assume the probability of
success or you can look back at
historical similar data to just infer it
and then doing calculations like this
becomes super straightforward and again
in industry you'll see cases like this
all the time so I hope you enjoyed this
video if you did smash the like button
also leave a comment down below and tell
me where you've used the binomial
distribution I'll see you all next time
until then Richard
on data